you're like cuz that's not getting
annoyed future I'm happy
hello I'm Kara Theobald and this is my
after 60 second interview challenge of
course is being filmed it's not for our
own pleasure which superpower would help
you do your job better photographic
memory what is the secret to success
work hard which part would you do you
wish you had the chance to play or
direct Marlon Brando on the waterfront
if you were stranded on a desert island
what film TV box that game would you
take with you Dwyre age 5 what did you
want to be when you grow up I wanted to
play in goal for Liverpool looking back
now what do you see is your big break
Rome for HBO which accents do you find
the easiest hardest to do I find
American easiest and English actually
quite hard to do British 4p what are
your tips for auditioning play the
character don't try and get the part
what do you most admire in your field
dedication and hard work what's the
worst thing that has ever happened to
you on set I had to wear a very very
small speedo and I fell out of what made
you want to be an actor I wanted to be
an actor because I play the line of The
Wizard of Oz and just realize it was
incredible infinite you could do for a
living my name is Michael Fox and this
is my BAFTA 62nd challenge what's the
secret to success I haven't found it yet
but hard work hopefully let's say hard
work what's your top tip for learning
lines learn them learn them night before
just before you go to bed and then when
you wake up in the morning BAM they're
all in there that's why I do or maybe
two nights before not just the night
before what or who made you want to
become an actor mr. bean I look like if
so I thought well I might as well see
this
what's the hardest thing about your job
the hardest thing about your job is not
having a job at any given time when
you've got a job and it's it's pretty
good so the hardest thing about your job
is not having a job well sure a vice for
aspiring actors keep on plugging away
never stop plugging away and then make
your own stuff if no one's giving you a
job then just make your own theater make
your own scripts just make your own
decisions take take control of it I was
very badly behaved at school and I think
a very wise teacher put me on the stage
to sort of channel it I kind of stayed
there really and I just had throughout
my time at school some really really
brilliant teachers who just sort of went
nope okay
we're going to do that with you that's
better and and it worked and I'm still
here
so yeah I'm still quite by debate I like
Chris Morris day today for us I as an
actor I don't know maybe Blackadder like
a bear Blackadder I say in the First
World War as well sometimes I didn't I
didn't go to drama school I I went to
university and read English a bit not a
lot but a little bit and I just I've
always enjoyed words and language and
and I think that's quite a good thing if
you want to be an actor make sure that
you like words and talking I quite like
talking I had always had such a passion
for the Arts as it has an umbrella over
subject and and when I was younger my
daddy's to show me these wonderful films
the ghost and mrs. Muir and all these
really beautiful old films and he had
such a passion about it but it never
sort of explored himself and mmm and I
just got to a point where all I would do
was was watch films or
spend every inch my student loan going
for theater and I thought I should do
something about this there must be a
reason why and I just thought I'd give
it a go I mean we just um tentatively
and naively I sort of built up sort of
going going to little auditions bit by
bit and eventually casting director had
remembered my information my name and
got me into read for a part which then
kept snowballing and and got very close
to what could have been very big part
and then subsequently because of that
despite not getting it my now agent had
kept his ear to the ground and wondered
who this strange unknown idiot was
wandering around trying to trying to
nail some massive role and so to me on
and and then from there it's amazing
what what it can do for someone's sort
of self-esteem and confidence when
someone says despite lack of on paper
credentials they they take you on I feel
really lucky in the people I've worked
with so far I've only ever been
brilliant and I'm yet to work with
someone who isn't anything other than
lovely but Neil McCormick the director
of Albertus was amazing in that he
despite having never really done
anything and also playing this this lead
character gave me so much creative space
to play around and and allowed me to do
different things and each take and
that's quite rare I really expected to
be directing in a way a choreographer
would die
something and and and be precise and
exact every time and that was a
wonderful process to have gone through
to start to learn to not be afraid to
experiment and try things out when I was
younger gone with a win just used to
blow my mind we just used to sit down on
Christmas Day in the evening watch the
whole thing and I think I was only about
thirteen when I first actually sat
through the whole thing and haven't
fallen this because it's such a long
movie normally when you're nine it's
very exciting because even only because
that character she's so you just want to
slap her and and she's straighting and
annoying wonderful and eccentric and
that'll be fun but you can't remake that
movie that's wrong but that would have
been cool it must bother well now that
sounds ridiculous to say it's for talent
but I knew no one and that and whilst
they think it is important and it's and
the more I've worked the more I have
learnt that it's okay to be confident
enough to introduce yourself to people
especially if you admire them when I was
at the 42 after 42 in LA it was
wonderful to be encouraged to go up to
people that you normally wouldn't you
just put your head down and walk past to
say hello my name is and you know have a
conversation I mean that is an important
thing but talent will shine through you
know if it's only knowing someone I
think you'll trip up eventually so I
just hope this is so which film or TV
program has most influenced you that's
really hard one of the first films I saw
was Billy Elliot and I think that's just
an amazing film and amazing performances
so maybe that and Titanic who's the
unsung hero on a set will everyone in
the crew it's it's and I always complain
I'm so tired
you know maybe makeup artist because
they are they're the earliest or the
ADEs and it's I always makes me want to
stop complaining when I
what's the secret success I don't know
it I wish someone would tell me if you
could have any other job on set what
would it be and why
I probably be lighting I love how you
know you create saddle quickly sorry how
did you get an agent at drama school she
came to see me in one of my first shows
and she was the only agent I met I'm
very indecisive and I knew she was the
one I love her who do you make friends
with first on set maybe catering if you
were stranded on a desert island which
film TV or video game books 8 would you
take what I've already seen it but
Breaking Bad so probably not that now
which film what that was fun
hello I'm Carrie Theobald and this is my
BAFTA 62nd challenge who should play the
next James Bond and I'll do it
however go age 5 what did you want to be
when you grew up
I think I wanted to be a vet or a Blue
Peter presenter which superpower would
help you do your job better being able
to fly because I just think life would
be generally better I don't know if it'd
help my job I'd like to fail sooner
what three things do you need to do your
job you need yourself and an agent and
someone who wants to give you a job if
you were stranded on a desert island
what film TV box a video
with the Back to the Future trilogy
who's the first person you make friends
with on set the rumors because they tell
you where you have to be who's the
unsung hero on set the runners
tell you they have to be a fifty
everyone like I'm winning
who's your guru I don't know I have a
guru I think you learn something from
everyone who you work with who should
play the next Doctor Who
I'll do it I'll play Doctor Who and
chose one you're like cuz that's not
getting tonight future I'm happy
hello I'm Kara Theobald and this is my
after 60 second interview challenge of
course is being filmed it's not a
pleasure in the movie of your life who
would you play no who would play you
probably Rowan Atkinson he played the
older version of me and the younger
version would be Michael Cera which
accent do you find the easiest / hardest
to do and you know literally can't even
tell you because it's like super cute so
if that was easy or hard age 5 what did
you want to be when you grew up I wanted
to play in goal for Liverpool how do you
spend breaks during filming grabbing a
cup of tea
three mint Parker how did you get an
agent
I sent out a million headshots and CVS
and then eventually one broke down and
took me on tell us something we don't
know about you I have a horse which film
or TV program has most influenced you
that's really hard one of the first
films I saw was Billy Elliot and I think
that's just an amazing film and amazing
performances
maybe that what's the one piece of
advice you would give to your 16 year
old self I don't know for my 16 year old
self all of us in 20 advice so I would
just these are great this is good fun
this would be good for a party party do
I win
I think I won
[Music]
[Music]